make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay we're picking back up again with uh
spider-man which is the conclusion of
the story where peter parker meets
miles morales for the very very first
time right peter parker from the main
marvel universe
meets the ultimate spider-man miles
morales and the whole idea behind this
is that we pick up with peter parker
following his kind of encounter
alongside
miles with mysterio who use basically
use the kind of robot version of himself
to move into the ultimate universe or to
travel to the ultimate universe
uh peter parker has essentially traveled
to meet uh the ultimate universe's
version
of gwen stacy and mary jane watson now
keep in mind the last time they
saw spider-man it was their version of
peter parker and he died
and largely there was just kind of the
grieving process that went into it now
one of the things that we talked about
in the early miles morales comics that
we did
is that there did come a point when
miles took on the spider-man costume
and was met by aunt may and and gwen
stacy and they were kind of like look if
you're gonna do this
understand that you're living up to a
legacy much bigger than yourself right
you don't just simply put on the
spider-man costume and do your thing
you're living up to the legacy that my
nephew created uh and you stand
for everything he stood for so this is
not a thing to take lightly right so it
was kind of
initially they were against it but it's
one of these things we're just kind of
like okay you know we can sort of get on
board once they realize the character
of miles morales and what he had to
offer but the problem with this is that
when peter shows up he's wearing the
original spider-man costume and as soon
as aunt may sees this she gets pissed
right because he basically showed his
face
and her thought is as some kind of a
some kind of a joke right gwen stacy
shows up and starts kicking the crap out
of
out of peter parker thinking that he's
pulling a stunt too and it's not until
miles shows up and says
no no no it's really actually peter
right it's not somebody pulling a
pulling a trick or something like that
not somebody being a jerk i don't really
know of a reasonable human being that
would show up on the doorstep
of a woman and like basically two chicks
who lost
somebody close to them dressed as that
person right i mean if somebody were to
do that i would wholly like i would
stand by and just watch them get the
crap kicked out of them i'd record it
and then just be like
yeah man this guy kind of had it coming
like that'd be my response
i'd be like yeah man like they were kind
of a dick they sort of had this coming
right nobody do anything
let them get their just desserts but uh
this is actually peter right this is
actually peter parker here and when
miles comes to his rescue that's when
aunt may
and gwen stacy basically start to listen
right and peter's initial response is
like like i thought initially i died
i thought something happened like i
didn't really know what was going on how
i ended up here
you know i've only recently been putting
the pieces together i never should have
come here right i never should have come
here to this place you know i'm sorry i
did this to you and then basically aunt
may passes out right now at that point
we switch over to the ultimate universe
tony stark and nick fury right now nick
fury we've talked about before
ultimate universe iron man we've never
really had a big discussion about one of
the big things to understand here
is that ultimate iron man when he first
showed up was designed to be a more
grounded version of tony stark from the
main level universe right so
not as intelligent because even tony in
the main marvel universe his
intelligence
even for the realm of comics
borderline's questionable right like how
could a person possibly be that smart
this version of tony is really smart but
he is a version of intelligence we would
expect to see here in the real world
right hence the nature of the ultimate
universe
kind of reflection of the real world the
way it exists now and so he's not really
able to pick up or really figure out
what mysterio what's what's going on
with mysterio's character right how to
reverse engineer the circuitry where the
signals coming from any
all that kind of stuff the the reality
of this is there's an infinite number of
universes out there right and tony just
doesn't have the ability to trace his
signal back to its origin point now if
this were in the main marvel universe
the main marvel tony stark would have
figured it out like that but he would
have figured it out
so fast because it's what the story
called for but the idea of the ultimate
universe was to write more realistic
stories right and
really if you're talking about an
infinite number of universes there
really wouldn't be a way to trace the
signal all the way back to its origin
point because it's not like it's a rope
that leaves from the main marble
universe and all they have to do is just
follow the breadcrumbs to get to its
location it doesn't really work that way
at least not for
for anybody here and so at the end of
the day tony doesn't really have any
answers here he's like the only way for
me to really get some answers is to talk
to that alternate reality version of
spider-man to talk to peter parker it's
the only way for me to really figure out
what it is that's going on here now the
funny comment he makes is i'm surprised
that you let miles morales run around
with peter parker right i figured he
would have cracked him over the head
thrown him into a hole
uh and and basically grabbed like the
the main peter and done the same thing
right kind of you know kept miles
morales under wraps so that he wouldn't
really have any idea what's going on
and then basically took peter and and
just kind of locked him up but the idea
behind this is that fury
really feels a bit of you know regret
when it comes to peter right peter was
never
properly trained to become a superhero
he was never properly trained he was
never really inducted the way that he
was supposed to be he was just kind of
allowed to do his thing and that led to
his eventual death and nick fury felt a
lot of responsibility for that that's
why when you go and you read cataclysm
that there's a lot of focus put on nick
fury and the guilt he feels for the
death of peter parker because when he
could have trained him or he could have
helped him to become a better hero he
didn't
instead it was just kind of him doing
his thing and so with that guilt in mind
along with promises that he made it's
kind of like we're just gonna let them
work it out together right which is
actually the right move
the best move for nick fury to make is
is really for peter on meg when stacy to
all kind of come to terms with this on
their own and so
once ame wakes up you basically have
peter like telling stories you know to
to miles into gwen stacy them sharing
stories with him that kind of a thing
and kind of going back and forth right
and peter's coming to this realization
there's massive differences between this
reality and the one that he's from
now we as the reader know that one of
the funny things that goes on
is gwen stacy kind of starts poking and
prodding and is like is there a version
of me
in your universe and peter's like yeah
but she's a little bit older than you
are you know she's about my age and
she's like well i mean you know like
are you dating her and peter's like i
mean not really like i'm basically
dating mary jane watson right which is
what gwen stacy calls
and then as soon as as soon as this kind
of explanation goes on that mary jane is
like a supermodel which she's not in the
ultimate universe right she's just like
a nerdy girl
when it's like she's a supermodel and
all that kind of stuff like when stacy's
kind of shocked to find out that like
mary jane watson is this hugely popular
world-renowned model and it's kind of
like wow that's a little crazy
but when she starts asking uh what about
me right like what am i then like what's
going on with me peter's like
we should we should probably talk about
something else
[Laughter]
i don't have the heart to tell you that
the green goblin threw you off a bridge
and i shot my my webbing at your foot
and broke your neck in the process uh
because that's basically what happened i
don't care what anybody says
she was not dead before spider-man got
there i don't care what anybody says
but uh you know it's it's kind of an
interesting thing because it's like
there are parts of his reality he
doesn't really want to divulge because
who knows how gwen stacey would react if
it was like well you're dead and i'm the
reason why then it's kind of like get
out of this house right you know i don't
want you here
but it's really kind of new to her to
learn it really fascinating for her to
learn
that there's whole other worlds and
dimensions out there now for her part
aunt may is a lot more reserved here
right she's not nearly as excited as
when stacey is you know she's kind of
breaking bracing herself with the idea
that it's not actually peter parker
that's like well we don't really know if
it's peter parker we don't really know
if it's him right we don't know that's
the case
it could be somebody else pretending to
be him now and in fact like it really is
him
we know that miles morales believes that
gwen stacy believes it but aunt mae's
doing this because in her heart of
hearts
if she gives into this and then it turns
out to be false she'd lose it right like
it would just be the most crushing
experience because for her
when she kind of asked peter you know
what led you to be to become this person
right when he kind of starts talking to
her about like uncle ben
uncle ben's the reason why he does this
that okaben of course is dead in his
reality
but the fact that that he could have
saved uncle ben and he didn't is the
reason why he became a superhero the way
that he did
and the idea that he could he could
basically help other people and in a lot
of ways a tone for his past mistake
he basically runs off the statement with
great power and then she finishes it
comes great responsibility now it should
be
must come great responsibility the fact
that this is a lesson that peter was
taught by uncle ben
tells aunt may everything she needs to
know that it really is him
and that's what she kind of gives
herself over and says we thought like
like we
lost you right we lost you and we didn't
even get to say goodbye and that's the
important thing here right that's the
important thing to understand
that's why aunt may kept herself
reserved in this part right because
if she had said like okay yeah you're
probably peter and let her whole self
believe it and then it turned out to
just be some alternate reality version
of peter who was evil or something like
that but it wasn't like the this
alternate reality counterpart to the one
that she knew which is to say
a good guy who fights the good fight and
does what heroes do
then it would have broken her in her
entirety right like the the inability of
her to say goodbye
the chances she the fact that she never
got to tell peter that she was proud of
him
that she loved him but to never say like
never be able to say i'm sorry or any of
that stuff
right to basically like confess or to to
kind of get to say her last goodbyes to
him is something that's always haunted
her
having peter here this alternate reality
version of peter even though she knows
it's not her actual nephew she knows
it's not that peter parker from the
the ultimate universe gives her a chance
to effectively say goodbye right to say
her goodbyes
and and you know indirectly say it to
peter parker from ultimate universe to
give her closure
it's basically what this does something
that she's never had this entire time
and so miles morales looking out the
window realizes uh okay
shields on their way we need to go right
because shield is a lot more seedy
in the ultimate universe that they are
in the main marvel universe in the main
marvel universe they're still kind of
jerks but like they're more inclined to
work with you than against you and the
ultimate universe they're like a like a
like a police force almost right i mean
not
specifically but in terms of like how
they function right like they do their
thing
and all there are just people who stand
in the way is basically all that it is
but of course
peter ends up saying goodbye to uh to
everybody here and then of course he
ends up getting in the car with
uh nick fury miles morales and it's kind
of a funny thing because nick fury asks
like is there a nick fury where you come
from and he's like yeah
but he's kind of a white guy and then
like nick fury's like sorry to hear that
man
which is kind of a funny thing but again
it gives aunt mae the closure she needs
and that's why when the story came out
it was so huge
it was wrapping up all these plot
threats right all these little things
that have been left hanging
and the reality is that if anybody but
brian michael bendis had taken this over
we probably would have never seen this
right but bendis started off
with the ultimate spider-man he
originally created it it makes sense
that he would basically end it here and
kind of continue things on with miles
and that's why
spider-man is so important it's one part
wrapping up plot threads that vendors
never got to wrap up
after the death of peter parker in the
ultimate universe in the cataclysm story
and it was a way to kind of officially
transition into miles and we'll find
more
you know find out more why that's the
case when we get once we get to the end
of this but when he when he really meets
with you know tony stark he's kind of
like okay so there's a few differences
here like one the tony stark in my
universe stopped drinking a while ago
which nick fury loves and two it's
obvious this guy's not as smart
and so with with tony kind of being like
look like i need to know where his home
is i need to know
where your universe is uh when peter
starts to point him in that direction
then it turns into okay
then we could at the very least figure
out how to get you back right we could
figure
we could figure out how to reverse
engineer this stuff now make no mistake
tony stark's not doing this out of the
goodness of his heart tony stark's doing
this one part because he was directed by
nick fury but two
because he can get something out of it
right i mean this is a level of
technology that tony just doesn't have
access to being able to attain this
technology and use it for his own ends
it's a huge benefit right it's something
that he desperately wants here and so
once once they're basically looking at
the broadcast
that mysterio has been putting out you
know over the internet you know all day
long and for how many days he's been
here
miles picks up on the fact that one of
these buildings is actually in brooklyn
right he's like one of these buildings
is in brooklyn i'm familiar with it and
so they know exactly where it is
mysterio is operating out of right they
know his base of operations once they
locate that
nick fury calls in everyone and when i
say everyone i mean
an entire shield strike team alongside
spider-man and alongside the ultimate
thor
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]